Salut, je suis actuellement Centrafrique, à Bangui.
La Centrafrique, c’est un pays d’Afrique Equatoriale qui est très mal connu
et qui est dans une situation humanitaire assez désastreuse.
Fin 2012, une coalition de groupes rebelles principalement musulmans appelée Séléka
prend le contrôle d’une grande partie de la République Centrafricaine.
En Mars 2013, ils pénètrent dans la capitale, Bangui, et renversent le gouvernement.
Ce coup d’état est accompagné de violences extrêmes dans tous le pays.
Les rebelles de la Séléka pillent, violent et massacrent les populations civiles.
Ces exactions entraînent la formation de milices d’autodéfense,
principalement chrétiennes, les anti-balakas
qui elles-mêmes commettent de nombreuses atrocités.
Pendant plusieurs mois, le pays sombre dans le chaos et les violences intercommunautaires.
Les Nations Unies parlent même de situation pré-génocidaire.
C’est le début d’une longue crise sécuritaire et humanitaire qui dure depuis près de 6 ans.
Il y a vraiment une ambiance hyper…
C’est impressionnant de voir les chirurgiens sur la personne et tout…
J’ai l’impression que les journées, c’est ça en permanence, tout le temps, tout le temps
ils courent chez MSF, ils courent.
L’affaiblissement de notre état, ça ne date pas d’aujourd’hui.
Ca ne vient pas seulement avec les sélékas,
on a courbé l’échine sous d’autres rebelles avant.
On parle de 14 groupes armés aujourd’hui, il y en a partout.
Et aujourd’hui, on se retrouve dans une situation extrêmement délicate.
Pas d’armée, pas de forces de sécurité, pas d’état qui fonctionne réellement.
Alors on va rentrer dans le bloc opératoire
où il y a une dame qui s’est fait tirée dans la jambe.
C’est une blessure qui est assez courante ici,
parce qu’on est dans un pays où il y a beaucoup d’armes d’assaut, beaucoup d’AK-47 comme ça.
Les chirurgiens ont vraiment l’habitude de faire ça
et en plus là, il s’agit d’une personne qui vient d’un endroit assez loin de la capitale.
Elle a dû être transférée par avion pour venir ici,
dans le seul endroit où les gens pouvaient l’opérer
et là ce qu’ils vont faire, c’est essayer de sauver la jambe,
essayer de faire en sorte qu’elle puisse remarcher avec ses deux jambes un jour
et si ça ne marche pas, ils vont être obligés de l’amputer.
Donc là, l’opération vient de se terminer et, malheureusement,
les deux chirurgiens n’ont pas réussi à sauver la jambe.
En fait, il se trouve que la balle était passée à travers une artère
et l’a sectionnée et le pied n’était plus irrigué
donc ils ont dû sectionné pour éviter qu’il y ait une nécrose,  enfin, tout une gangrène.
Pour une balle qui est passée dans sa jambe,
elle se retrouve avec une jambe qui est réduite au niveau de la cuisse.
Une balle, si ça ne tue pas, ça handicap, dans tous les cas.
Pour comprendre pourquoi aujourd’hui la Centrafrique est une zone de conflits,
il faut remonter jusqu’en 1903 lors de la création du pays par les Français.
Très vite, les colons sont rentrés dans une logique d’exploitation
des ressources humaines et naturelles très agressive.
Les centrafricains devaient cultiver le coton, le café, le caoutchouc
et également aménager le territoire colonial
notamment lors de la construction de la ligne de chemin de fer Congo-Océan
qui reliait le Congo à l’océan Atlantique.
Ils exploitaient les gens, presque pas de salaire,
on coupait les mains aux personnes qui ne produisait pas assez.
Les deux Guerres Mondiales, on en a souffert aussi énormément.
Il y avait la famine ici, à cause des guerres,
parce que tout ce qui était produit ici était ramassé pour envoyer au front.
Donc on a passé des moments extrêmements difficiles.
Entre la fin du 19 ème siècle et 1940,
environ la moitié de la population centrafricaine disparaît
dû à la violence coloniale et aux maladies qui en découlent.
Le pays obtient finalement son indépendance en 1960.
Mais depuis, la République centrafricaine vit au rythme des guerres civiles et des coups d’états.
C'est un handicap sévère pour qu'ils puissent trouver leur pain quotidien
Dans leurs familles, ce sont des personnes en trop.
Et une charge de plus
S’il n’y avait pas d’aide humanitaire à Bangui,
je pense que ça serait une catastrophe.
On va à Castor,
qui est la maternité qui est responsable de la plupart des naissances de Bangui.
Et là, ce qu’on va faire, c’est aller voir comment ils font ça sur le terrain.
- Vous constatez qu’il y a beaucoup moins de mortalité infantile grâce à vous, ici, par rapport à ailleurs?
- Nous avons contribué, effectivement, à réduire considérablement la mortalité,
la morbidité maternelle et néonatale,
à travers une prise en charge de qualité et de gratuité.
- Donc ça cumule à combien de naissances par mois ici?
- C’est environ autour de 800 naissances.
- 800 naissances par mois, ça fait 10 000 naissances par an presque, plus même.
- Exactement.
- C'est fou, c'est énorme.
Là, c'est la technique de la marche automatique.
Voilà !
Ça va bébé.
Il est en forme.
Maman!
Notre présence ici est très importante parce que nous avons sauvé beaucoup de vies.
Nous avons apporté beaucoup de secours à des mamans.
Tout le monde accourt vers nous.
24h/24h, nous reçevons des personnes.
Le truc que je trouve très impressionnant c'est que,
non seulement, c'est gratuit mais en plus, ils font vraiment un gros suivi
Ils prennent en charge les néonataux, les bébés prématurés.
Ils font de la prévention,
de l'éducation sur comment gérer un bébé,
comment le nourrir etc... donc c'est vraiment...
ils font un package global on va dire.
Il se trouve que cette maternité est juste en bordure
du quartier le plus chaud de Bangui qu'on appelle le PK5.
C'est le quartier d'où partent la plupart des émeutes dont on entend parler.
C'est un quartier où il y a des blindés de l'ONU qui circulent,
en fait on est juste à la lisière.
Donc en fait, ce sont des gens qui doivent gérer le quotidien de la naissance dans un contexte de crise.
Tous les évènements qui se déroulent à l'intérieur de PK5,
notamment des frictions entre les groupes d'autodéfense,
a une répercussion directe sur nous.
Les femmes n'arrivent pas à accéder à Caster pour accoucher dans de bonnes conditions.
- Donc c'est quand même dangereux de travailler ici.
- Effectivement, c'est un peu dangereux parce que, quand même,
nous sommes dans une zone encore très sensible de la capitale centrafricaine.
Et ça créer, un peu, une certaine psychose au sein du staff, d'abord,
et particulièrement de nos patients.
Puisque nous sommes habitués, nous savons comment maîtriser le stress
et nous sommes des humanitaires.
Notre rôle, c'est de sauver les gens qui sont en souffrance.
Voilà pourquoi nous sommes là. Donc, même si ça chauffe.
Nous avons des techniques de sécurité et on continue toujours notre travail.
Je pense que les humanitaires ont encore pour un bon moment leur place ici en Centrafrique.
Aujourd'hui, ça c'est clair. On a pas les moyens, dans ce pays,
militaires et humains, de régler par la force,
la question de la rébellion.
Alors est-ce qu’il est condamné à rester dans le chaos et la violence?
Si la situation doit s’améliorer, cela passe forcément par un accord de paix
entre le gouvernement au pouvoir et les milices rebelles.
Et justement, un accord a été signé début Février 2019,
une avancée qui pourrait peut-être entraîner la fin du conflit qui touche le pays depuis 2013.